une époque de textos et de commentaires
facebook bourré de fautes d'orthographe
l'exercice auquel ses élèves ce livre
semble sortir d'une autre époque
la dictée pgl on est pourtant sa 28e
année 75 élèves de 5e et 6e année
meilleure connaissance du français écrit
à l'épreuve dans ces grandes finales
internationales
cette fillette de colombie-britannique
est confiant et espère faire un zéro
faute
oui ce sont les meilleurs des trois cent
douze mille élèves qui ont participé à
la sélection
c'est le ministre de l'éducation du même
qui donne la dictée nous avons appris
que les gens produisait en moyenne 800
kg de détritus par année un exercice de
valorisation du français et de
coopération internationale
pour moi c'est un peu les jeux
olympiques jeunesse du français que les
enseignants soient toujours bien formés
mais de manière générale je pense qu'on
enseigne bien français c'était la
première dictée depuis la mort de son
fondateur paul gérin lajoie qui fut le
premier ministre de l'éducation du
québec
son fils françois prend la relève si son
legs vivant et puis pour ce qui est des
7 millions qui ont déjà participé
c'est des gens aussi qui s'attend à ce
que la dictée pgl continue les diktats
exporté dans le reste du canada et
ailleurs dans le monde
ça c'est super important que en afrique
d'ici 2060
c'est le continent il y aura le plus de
francophones ils sont rangés à 90
millions pour les parents des enfants en
compétition
la lecture est l'élément essentiel de
leur préparation mais lis énormément ces
quatre ou cinq livres par semaine pour
mais déjà gagnant mais ça il doit faire
attention à l'écriture même aux textos
mais à la baisse une grande lectrice
donc c'était sa préparation à la juste
constat raska faisait d'habitude pour
plusieurs parents la meilleure garantie
pour l'avenir du français restent les
jeunes qui seront bien le lire et
l'écrire ici monsieur marsolais radio
canada montréal